اهلا بكم انا الان في ولايه الجزيره وفي
حضرتها مدينه ود مدني هذه المدينه التي
تبعد حوالي 180 كم عن مدينه الخرطوم تحولت
هذه المدينه لمركز كبير للايواء للفارينه
من الحرب في الخرطوم هذه المدينه الان
تستقبل اعداد كبيره جدا من المساعدات التي
وصلت المركز الملك سلمان للاغاثه والاعمال
الانسانيه في اطار المساهمه في سد الحوجه
الانسانيه جراء هذه الحرب وصلت خمس طائرات
هنالك طائره تم توزيعها في ولايه البحر
الاحمر بالتحديد في مدينه بورسودان وفي
ضواحيها كذلك ولكن الان وصلت اربع طائرات
الى هذه
المدينه محمله بالمواد الاغاثيه
والايوائيه اذا كما تتابعون هذه الشاحنه
اعدت خصيصا من وزاره الصحه
السودانيه الاستلام اعداد كبيره جدا من
المحاليل الوريديه التي وصلت في اطار
مساهمه مركز الملك سلمان للاغاثه والاعمال
الانسانيه لاغاثه المتضررين جراء هذه
الحرب بعد قليل هذه الشاحنه ستنقل اعداد
كبيره جدا من المحاليل الوريديه التي وصلت
قبل قليل وفي الداخل ايضا هنالك عدد من
التفاصيل التي سنتابعها لحظه بلحظه اذا
هذه عباره عن بطانيات ومراتب يتم الان
نقلها من الشاحنات الكبيره الى هذه
المخازن استعدادا لعمليه التوزيع التي
ستتم وفق جداول محدده ووفق عمليه منظمه تم
احكامها من قبل مركز الملك سلمان وكذلك
ايضا يعني المراكز وايضا المنظمات التي
تعمل في مجال العون الانساني وايضا باشراف
مفوضيه العون الانساني هنا في هذه المدينه
وكذلك ايضا في عموم السودان كما تتابعون
هذه هي المحاليل الوريديه التي تستعد
وزاره الصحه
لاستلامها من مركز الملك سلمان
للاغاثه والاعمال الانسانيه
هذه الكميات الكبيره سيتم توزيعها لكل
المناطق المتاثره والمتضرره جراء هذه
الحرب كما نتابع ايضا في هذا الجانب هنالك
عدد من المواد الغذائيه التي وصلت ضمن هذه
الشحنه الكبيره
وهنالك عدد ايضا من المستلزمات التي تتعلق
بالاستخدام الضروري في المطابخ والاواني
المنزليه تستخدم ايضا في اوقات الضروره
واوقات الكوارث تقول الاحصائيات 1.7 مليون
شخص تاثروا بهذه الحرب وان هنالك 170 الف
اسره تحتاج لمساعده عاجله طبعا لابد من
الاشاره الى منظمه اضافه لمساعدات الكوارث
والتنميه والتي تعتبر هذه المنظمه شريكه
الوطني لمركز الملك سلمان للغاته والاعمال
الانسانيه اذ تقوم هذه المنظمه بالاشراف
على ايصال هذه المساعدات لمستحقيها
بالتعاون مع السلطات الرسميه محمد عثمان
العربيه من ولايه الجزيره مدينه ودمدني
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات